c'est plate à chronique s'est plaint et
millions cela ça fait 15 ans qu'il n'a
pas fait un bon film
jeudi on me dire tu sais quoi arrête
déjà avec des navets raciste la doit à
prévert critiquer mon travail c'est vrai
que c'est le seul qui a mal tourné tout
un board and will rain que j'aimerais
bien en est mort mais louis lichou tu as
pensé à appeler pour que maistre pour la
clôture mais man c'est ce que je te
disais dans le message le bon mais moi
je ne le connais pas bah non mais tu
l'appelles et tu dis que c'est toi jeudi
j'appelle les cheveux à l'eau c'est moi
tu vois tu vas me dire ah ouais c'est
pas comme chez british ou non plus à
citoyens alors bata quand même
wayne rooney bon de la paix le
bourgmestre lydia sava copains tu vas
bien apparemment ils ont des problèmes
dans le jardin il ya leurs voisins et
fait pression actions sectorielles sur
la clôture toilettes changeait sa 7e
plaît pas elle se trouve pas dans cette
excuse moi mais ça ça vaut bien la peine
de faire de la télévision
ce garçon fait son trou dans le showbiz
ça se fait pas en 5 minutes c'est oui
c'est la même chose pour la véranda
qu'elle veut en fait semblant de ne pas
comprendre tu sais très bien qu'on a eu
des difficultés à cause de la chaudière
tu as demandé à aider pour la véranda à
que je sache
tu veux pas aidé pour lui pour que m tu
veux pas aidé pour la véranda qu'elle
véranda en a marre de quoi tu parles
si ce garçon veut garder son argent et
l'endroit là c'est pas une question la
drogue soit enfin jordanie est ce que
une fois on lui a demandé de l'est et là
je demande juste une belle petite
véranda pour qu'on puisse profiter du
buzz petit jardin avec papa mais non
c'est trop con mais t'es malade ou quoi
une véranda ça coûte une blonde tu t'en
parle comme si c'était un percolateur tu
es folle ou quoi car ton argent tu sais
moi de cartons un champ c'est un petit a
fait un petit paquet mais là la banque
et après quand on le met la banque après
que ce qui se passe aux moeurs et après
qu'on meure où il va l'argent à l'état
elle est un élément butin de questions
raconte manger à l'état g
11 11 11 euros 10 11 euros distincts je
fais une chronique je présente pas le jt
difficile ça peut être un prêt aussi
entrée en bourse très bas mais pas
question raconte qui sur un prêt pas une
[ __ ] je vends des vannes seront pas
des bagnoles quand même c'est vrai en
plus dû à paris dès que la vispa
paraît-il pas tu achètes jeu par une eau
pétillante à ça te coûte le prix d'un
chien ici un jour calme faut arrêter de
comparer vous êtes fou quoi c'est vrai
mais enfin cette pac a voulu aller en
france aussi je suis resté situerait à
pouvoir d'achat beaucoup plus laisse
tomber dany un dessert te ferait plaisir
show ouest est uf et du dessert en effet
je veux bien mais qu'est ce que tu as
envie
un bis un sabayon à savarin à feuilleter
ou une pièce montée je peux faire venir
une fille qui sort d'un gâteau m'en
allais pourquoi tu qui je comprends pas
et je suis premier aider et si je peux
aider jeune quand même eh bien tu sais
ce que tu vas commencer à faire pour
aider tu vas laisser tes 11 euros sur la
table pour le poulet
yves monge je suis une chronique en
france j'ai eu il ya mangé ui 2 1 er m o
vous avez vous avez youtube le bon bout